what can you say about the escape and
could something like that happen now
he is back to have the Nevada State
Prison System and from an escaped
prisoner to a severe Staffing shortage
the director of the department of
corrections may have inherited quite a
mess thanks for joining us here at six
I'm Denise Valdez and I'm Brian Loftus
the eight news now investigators have
uncovered numerous problems inside state
prisons the director doing his first
sit-down interview with eight news now
investigator Vanessa Murphy who joins us
live Denise and Brian you might remember
the previous director of the Department
of Corrections never sat down with us
for an interview while he held the job
James arenda has been back on the job
for about a month he promises the
department will be more transparent
when you are not holding this job and
you saw what was unfolding here what
were your thoughts
at that the system is actually failing
that it has to someone has to be able to
correct the system that was out there
James arenda is back as the Director of
the Nevada Department of Corrections
after he left with more than three years
on the job in 2019. Governor Joe
Lombardo re-hiring him to fix the state
prison system what is the first crisis
you've had to deal with it's the
Staffing I think the whole Staffing is
the whole crisis and also with the
suicides
there might be a correlation between the
Staffing and the uh and the suicides
that were happening the 8 news now
investigators uncovering several inmate
suicides over the past year including
two within two days at High Desert State
Prison zarenda says in addition to try
to address Staffing with a vacancy rate
as high as 50 percent in some prisons
he's also trying to be proactive rather
than reactive trying to come up with
solutions to see what went wrong or what
can we do better in the future so we
could prevent this or have be more on
top of it so that we don't have the
suicide rates as we go on he says he's
also trying to address infrastructure
like fencing for example at Southern
desert Correctional Center where a
convicted murderer escaped and had been
missing for a few days before anyone
noticed last September to me it was all
basic training that was never followed
zarenda says he wants to try to bring
volunteers inside prisons and reach out
to ex-offenders who are successful he
stresses the importance of re-entry
programs ways to keep people who are
released from prison and back in the
community from committing crimes again
he says the programs he had in place
when he left were pretty much gone when
he returned
and Vanessa zorinda says you know there
are beds available inside of our state
prisons the issue is not space but again
it's Staffing